every time a new MacBook Pro comes out
two things happen a bunch of people get
really excited because there's a cool
new laptop in town and a bunch of other
people get really mad because it's not
everything they wanted it to be well a
new MacBook Pro just came out and guess
what both things happened a lot of
people are excited about the fact that
this new MacBook Pro only weighs three
pounds and is thinner than the MacBook
Air and has this hilariously huge
trackpad and great speakers and an
amazing screen and comes in this cool
new Space Gray letter on the other side
a lot of people are not happy that
they're gonna have to spend eighteen
hundred dollars on this that's just for
the cheap model they're also not excited
that they're gonna have to spend more
money on a bunch of dongles because the
only ports on this thing are for USB C
Jack's and they're really not happy that
they can't get more than 16 gigs of RAM
or better graphics than this offers
here's the thing they're both right if
you want the most computer you can
possibly get don't buy this there are
lots of Windows machines you'll like
better but if you want a basic laptop
for doing basic laptop things and you
can afford this one you'll love it
but I don't want to talk about any of
that I want to talk about the touch bar
this thin strip of glass above the
keyboard that Apple thinks is going to
totally change the way you use your
laptop off to the right there's a touch
ID sensor which you can use to log into
your computer or pay for stuff online
the rest of the glass changes all the
time the touch bar doesn't do anything
strictly new or incredible at least not
yet right now it's mostly a tool bar for
easy access for the features and menus
that you use most often just to give you
an example if you're in mail you can
find easy formatting tools for making
your messages look fancy in Safari you
can see your bookmarks or a list of tabs
you have open it's a really fast way to
scroll through photos and photos dates
and calendar or your video timeline and
final cut you can use it for searching
in maps or controlling the music and
iTunes and here's the best one ready
emoji bar this is worth the price all by
itself
you asked me apples hoping that this is
just the beginning that developers do
weird and wild things that none of us
could possibly imagine and that might
happen but until then it's really just a
tool bar for easier access to stuff you
can already do and sometimes it's
actually annoying for instance instead
of being able to just go press a button
to pause your music you have to now tap
the tiny little left arrow and then go
over and find the button and press it
it's not the worst it's just a little
bit slower and in general not every
feature you want is going to be in the
touch more someday I hope you can
customize it a lot more someday by the
way is kind of the whole story of the
MacBook Pro someday USBC will be
ubiquitous someday the touch bar might
be awesome and useful and totally
impossible to live without someday we
might all live in VR and all the people
saying we need more power or going to be
proven right and someday this computer
or one just like it
is going to be much less expensive until
then here's where I land if you don't
need a new computer yet there's nothing
so incredible here that you have to go
drop $1,800 and buy it right now but
when you do need to upgrade and you want
a computer that's good and future proof
and it's going to work for life in like
2022 you're going to want to computer a
lot like this one I mean it has an emoji
bar what else do you want
you